[Music]
you're watching Al Jazeera time to recap
the headlines more than 2 000 people
have been killed in Morocco in the worst
earthquake to hit the country in more
than a hundred years the magnitude 6.8
Tremors struck late on Friday night
a major search and rescue operation is
continuing troops and Emergency Services
have scrambled to reach remote Mountain
Villages where people are still feared
trapped
mile people in Morocco continue to
experience fear in the aftermath of the
Quake many victims have been sleeping on
the streets after the government warned
them against returning to their homes
our diplomatic editor James Bays is at
the G20 Summit in New Delhi where
leaders have expressed their condolences
to the people of Morocco we can join him
there now and so James the earthquake
Morocco casting a shadow over the
Gathering there
foreign
ERS have spoken about what has happened
in Morocco and sent their condolences to
the people and to the king of Morocco at
this time of course there's plenty else
going on in the G20 and we'll talk about
that in a moment but I'm joined by the
spokesperson for the UN Secretary
General Stefan dejarik right now Stefan
let's start with Morocco what is the
what what are the comments from the
Secretary General on what's happened and
what's the UN going to do well first of
all the Secretary General is extremely
sad to learn of the news he spoke to the
ambassador of Morocco immediately
transmitting his condolences to the king
and the people of Morocco we have a
large team already that had been on the
ground doing development work at their
request we sent a disaster assessment uh
team which should be arriving shortly
and we're of course on standby waiting
if the Moroccan authorities require
International Help in which case we have
people and teams on standby ready to go
but we will do whatever we can to assist
the people of Morocco in this terrible
terrible tragedy let's turn to the G20
Summit here the Secretary General when I
spoke to him just a few days ago said
that there needed to be some big changes
in the Global Financial system and also
particularly on global debt he was very
worried about the poorest countries in
the world being in a development crisis
you've now had the final declaration is
the UN happy well I mean Secretary
General is not in the business of giving
pass fail uh notes to to documents that
come out of different groupings I think
what we've seen is a spirit of
compromise I mean as you know there was
a lot of chatter there there wouldn't
even be a statement we're very pleased
to see in that statement references to
the sustainable development goals the
secretary General's push for a um a
special fund to enhance our work on the
sustainable development goals but his
message really to the G20 as it was to
asean is it will be the G7 seven and to
to the countries in the north is more
action more ambition uh on and more
political will on on climate on on
development and a host of number of
challenges that we're facing today the
aid agency Oxfam said it was uninspiring
and underwhelming and skates over the
big issues of poverty inequality and
climate I mean you can make criticisms
that there are words in there but
there's no concrete action and there's
no concrete timelines again you know
we're we're not going to do a line by
line analysis I think there was it's a
testament to the leadership of the G20
and to its members that they agreed on
on a text that has a number of very
important uh points we've had over the
last few weeks a number of different
groupings meet in different parts of the
world the point is that in in less in
about a week or so they will all be
coming to New York the U.N let's
remember is the only grouping where 193
member states sit at the same table and
what we want to see during this general
assembly is strong ambition and strong
action and on all of the issues that
were that we're facing let me raise the
other huge issue that Secretary General
always raises which you just touched on
which is climbers he's made it clear
that he thinks the G20 have really the
most important role to play so they are
the biggest admitters and we're heading
towards not just the UN General Assembly
also the next cop meeting that is taking
place in Dubai is he convinced that
these countries are really doing enough
here given that they are the ones that
have the key to solving the property
everybody and especially the world's
largest emitters can do more and need to
do a lot more Stefan dejarik
spokesperson for the UN Secretary
General thank you very much for joining
us here on Al Jazeera the G20 Summit
continues we have the leaders arriving
where they are going to a memorial to
Gandhi at the moment and then they're
coming back here for the final session
the U.S President Joe Biden is missing
that final session he'll be flying in
about an hour's time for his next visit
he's going to Vietnam for a visit uh
Vietnam increasingly an important U.S
Ally the U.S trying to get Vietnam very
much in the U.S camp with regard to the
Rivalry between the U.S and China Sammy
all right thanks so much James Bays